Hello.
Welcome to the online track. Turbocharge
your agent retrieval with Turbo Comp.
My name is Shashi.
I'm a founder of Super Agent DKR.
Today, we will see how you can cut
memory cost of agent retrieval five
times
without breaking your search.
So, let's get into it.
Before we start the talk,
let's try to see what problem
we're trying to solve.
If you have used any agent or
general-purpose agent, you might see in
that as context grow,
the performance degrade.
And it is usually because of the KV
cache.
If you don't know KV cache,
think about like history of your
conversation.
If you have used the cloud-based models,
you probably have not heard of this
issue because they handled all the KV
cache by themselves.
But if you ever tried loading the
model
on your own device,
then you might have seen this issue
by yourself.
You need to load your model,
and then you also
need to load your context, and the KV
cache
grows as you your context grows.
And if you push the context far enough,
your KV cache might get bigger than
model size.
So, if you're using the Mac devices, it
gets even worse because hash, your
vector index,
all fight
over one shared pool pool of RAM.
So, basically, one thing is clear that
your embeddings are using
far more memory
than they need to.
So, by default,
it use the full precision, like 32 bits,
but search might just need
three or four bits.
That means you're wasting the five times
memory
on your retrieval.
So, before Turbo Quant,
people use different methods
to solve this problem.
So, one of them is a quantization.
So, quantization allows you to quantize
your model into 4-bit, 8-bits that
allows
model fits into your memory.
Model get
compressed and fit into your memory.
Next thing you probably seen in coding
agent is a context compaction.
So, when you reach to the end of the
context, the your context get
compacted
and it's summarized for the next
session.
Some people use a smaller embeddings.
Some use offloading of the CPU
or disk.
But, each of this has a trade-off.
You have to compromise your quality,
speed, or you probably need a special
hardware
to do that.
That's where the Turbo Quant comes in
the picture.
So, let's see what's a Turbo Quant.
So, Turbo Quant paper
released by the Google research team at
ICLR
2026 conference.
It is basically a compression algorithm
that store embeddings in KV cache in 3-4
bits instead of 32-bits.
And that's it.
Behind scene, it uses the the two
techniques.
One is
Polar Quant
is the another algorithm.
And next one is a QJL.
So, Polar Quant is basically
the compressed the vector.
And the QJL
fixes any error that
has been remaining.
So, as you can see there's full full
paper on this topic.
If you if you're from a machine learning
background, you can read this paper.
But if you're from the software
background,
you might find this paper pretty
technical
and mathematical.
The Google also released the launch post
on the Turbo Quant, which explains how
it works.
And they mentioned this QJL techniques,
which using only one bit,
and the polar quant.
So, you can go through this blog post if
you want.
But, in a nutshell, what Turbo Quant
says is do not store vectors in 32
32-bit.
Just
just store it into three to four bits.
And that's it.
The promise of this paper is basically
you can put this
vector into less than four bit
without losing the quality.
And that's the interesting part of the
compression.
And that's the magic the Turbo Quant has
under the hood.
One idea that worth understanding is
search doesn't care
what vector looks like.
It only cares what's the closest to your
query.
It doesn't matter it's a full precision
or it's a Turbo Quant.
If you use like a traditional
compression method,
you won't notice it until you see the
drop in the quality.
So, Turbo Quant basically
uses two stages.
It you can further distill down to
three.
In the first stage, Turbo Quant evened
out the data by shuffling the vector.
And then it rounds to the bucket using
the technique called scalar
quantization.
And in the last stage,
which is called QJL, it fixes the
remaining error
with only one bit.
And that's where the magic happens.
If you want to use Turbo Quant by
yourself,
then you probably need to know these
three stages or two stages.
And the only thing you need to care
about is you pick your budget, like what
bits you want to use.
And the good news is that everything
else is handled by the libraries itself.
So, you don't have to tune anything by
hand.
So, you need to decide basically
how far you can push before quality
drops.
So, ideal sweet spot by the industry is
3.5 bit.
But, you can go smaller
if it's if it's work for your use case.
But, in practice, you can land somewhere
near 4 bits. So, right now
the Turbo Quant has been
adopted by the most of the inference
engine that you might be already using.
For example, if you're using the local
models, you might be using the llama
CPP,
uh MLX, Ollama, LM Studio.
Everything will eventually get the Turbo
Quant
baked inside the
inference engine. So, you don't have to
worry about
doing anything by yourself.
Turbo Quant can be used
for the models KV cache for the
inference layer, but it could also be
used for your rag and vector search.
It can serve the both purpose.
It can compress the embeddings in your
index. If you're building
agents,
one approach that we built at Super
Agentic AI is Turbo Agent.
It's the open-source library
that allows you to use your
same agent framework, same vector
database. You just need to
swap the retrieval layer
and use Turbo Agent there,
and you will get the benefit of the
Turbo Quant.
You can take similar approach. You can
build your own tool
and use a Turbo Cont for your agent's
retrieval.
For Turbo agents, it allows you to keep
your
existing agent framework and existing
vector vector database.
So, the way it works is basically say
for example, if you have a Pinecone AI
agent,
only thing you need to do, use your
retriever,
whether you're using
Chroma DB or any other vector database,
you just need to swap the
indexing part
with the bits you are interested in.
And this is where all the magic happens.
We got agent, we ask the question.
First, we will run with plain
baseline float
32-bit index.
Um then we
compress and re-rank it with the smaller
size
and then run it again.
And by doing that, we'll get the same
results much smaller size.
We can see that demo right now in
action.
If you want to see the demo for
other vector databases like
SurrealDB or
Lance DB,
they are already available on the
GitHub.
You can You can play around with that.
But for now,
let's switch to the local demo.
So, I have a demo repo here.
So, what I can do, I can run the script.
So, first of all, let me show you the
script.
So, I have agent demo script.
Which basically loads the model.
The embedded
We have baseline retriever
and we have a turbo retriever.
And then we ask the question, it use the
local llama model.
Whatever you provided.
And
we run it and get the answer.
So, let's run the script.
And let's use the small model called
It's 2 billion model, so that it's
faster.
Now you can see we're using the quantri
embedding model. 0.6 billion
with
256 dimension.
And we're asking the question.
Now you can see the baseline has been
loaded with the float 32.
And it's using the index memory of
of 8 KB.
We need to wait for the model to be
loaded.
And then
we'll see the answer.
You probably need to wait for some time
to model to get loaded, but after that
you get the answer from the
32-bit float.
An agent has answered it.
Now we are using the turbo quant with
the comp and re-ranked.
Now you can see the index memory is just
1.6 KB.
Which is almost five times smaller than
what is being used by
float 32.
Now you we can you can see that
we got the same answer
uh from the turbo quant.
So,
both retrievers grounded answer is a
true.
But the memory difference you can see is
a five times smaller.
What change here is we haven't changed
any
agents. We haven't changed the
documents.
Only thing we did, we did change is a
retriever.
And that made And that made a big
difference.
Let's switch back to the slides.
Now we have another demo for the memory.
So that the rerank step is what keeps
reranking accurate.
So we have another demo.
I already ran because it took some time.
So it's basically
you have a float 32.
You have a float 32.
You have a turbo count.
You can see the quality and the speed
there.
You can see the result. It's a five-time
less memory and retrieval quality
preserved.
Turbo count isn't one option, but there
are some other approaches already
available in the market.
Turbo count
uses three to four bits.
Use one method for KV cache and the
vectors.
And the tooling is still emerging.
But there are some other approaches also
available in the industry like Rabbit
and you, which is available in Milvus,
which uses one to four bits.
And it is strong for the the big static
indexes.
But it only supports the vector search,
not the KV cache.
There's another approach, which is
F does eight bit.
And it is already available in VLLM and
SGLine. What you can take away from this
talk is basically
you need to change your mindset and
only compress for ranking.
As search only cares about the
vector which is closest.
Not how it look like.
You can try
Turbo Cont
and you can swap one of the retriever
that you currently using with the Turbo
Cont and see what
difference it makes.
Start small. Run recall and latency
benchmark on your own data.
See
what result you get.
And hopefully
you will see some magical results
in the retrieval if you use Turbo Cont
under the hood.
And if you need a further information
you can find uh Turbo Agents on GitHub.
You can fork it and make your own
version.
Or you can try this minimum
demos
that uses the Lance DB and Serial DB.
Or if you have any further questions,
you can reach out to me on X or LinkedIn
or GitHub.
And with that
thank you so much for listening to my
talk.
Thank you.